to see you thanks for joining us are you
surprised that this war is still going
on in Ukraine none at all I mean neither
side has any incentive to compromise in
any way Putin can't for him compromise
or negotiation is a sign of weakness and
weakness would be
putting him at risk of losing his power
and he's committed so many gross
atrocities murders rapes destruction of
of territory that the ukrainians have no
willingness to negotiate either and so
both sides are going to fight on neither
side at this point has a decisive
military advantage and so this is just
going to grind on and on and on and I
can imagine we'll be sitting here a year
from now and having the same
conversation how long do you think it
will go on for I think it'll go on until
one side collapses or the other side
collapses that there's that you know a
victory a Russian Victory happened
because Russia's not going to collapse
and the West is not going to allow
Ukraine to collapse well um Russia could
as the Russian military could collapse
in Ukraine I mean it's it's basically
physics if the ukrainians can physically
push them out of their country then
that's the collapse that I'm referring
to and on the other side if for example
um we stopped supporting Ukraine we stop
giving them military equipment if the if
if there's a change in government in
America let's say Donald Trump becomes
president and says I don't want to
support Ukraine anymore and there are
voices on the far right in America that
are suggesting that
um that could lead to the collapse of
the Ukrainian uh counter-offensive
um what about we spoke to you I think in
January you said the cleanest safest and
simplest way from deterring Putin from
invading Ukraine is to go after his
money yeah well we didn't do that we
only did that after we invaded so
sanctions um can be very powerful either
as a deterrent which we didn't use or as
a punishment which we are using but the
punishment is it's not going to change
his mind at this point if if we had gone
gone all guns blazing let's say six
months before this actual Invasion
um he might have said oh actually the
West is serious he didn't think we were
serious he didn't think that that we
would lock arms altogether and impose
these sanctions but he didn't think he
was serious though did we well I think
we did think he was serious he didn't
think he would invade I didn't even
think he would invade but but
um uh he's always been a serious
criminal and a serious murderer I mean I
I've been shouting from the rooftops for
10 years this man is much worse than you
think you should try to do anything you
can to contain him
but we just he invaded Georgia we didn't
do anything he took Crimea we didn't do
anything he carpet bombed Syria we
didn't do anything he poisoned people in
Salisbury we didn't do anything well we
did hardly hardly I mean we didn't
sanction a bunch of oligarchs we kicked
out a few diplomats they were replaced
by other diplomats
to me about how effective do you think
sanctions have been the ones that have
been implemented albeit as you say after
the event well there are several
different categories of sanctions we've
Frozen 350 billion dollars of Russian
Central Bank Reserves that's a lot of
money that they could have used for
their war effort that they're not using
we've gone after 40 of the top 118
oligarchs and hundreds of billions of
dollars is now Frozen from that which is
in in my opinion some of Putin's money
we have stopped a bunch of Russian Banks
from from engaging in in financial
activities in the west which means they
can't Finance their war that way which
is helpful but the big problem is
there's one huge elephant in the room
and that's oil and gas
every day Russia sells to the west and
to the east somewhere between 500
million and a billion dollars a day of
oil and gas and that money is used to
pay to kill ukrainians and until we can
figure out what to do with that this war
will go on or I should say Putin can can
Finance this war into perpetuity what
about
um funds being channeled through China
as is the allegation
well what what the bigger and more
serious allegation is that China is
going to start supplying lethal military
equipment to Russia Russia Russia is
running out of arms yeah they're so
they're in such bad shape Russia used to
be a big arms exporter they're in such
bad shape that they've had to go to the
only two countries that are so
sanctioned they don't care North Korea
and Iran if China were to enter the game
and give them weapons that would be a
game changer for Russia that would be
terrible for Ukraine and it could lead
to the Third World War
what is the likelihood of that happening
well um uh Secretary of State Anthony
blinken brought it up at the Munich
security conference last weekend
Chinese representatives in Moscow just
yesterday yeah so now on the other hand
China is a Mercantile country they
survive off of selling stuff all over
the world to us and many other people
and if they all of a sudden are doing
this nasty sort of you know killing of
ukrainians if we see a Chinese missile
an unexploded missile on the ground in
Ukraine that's going to lead many people
to call for sanctions call for economic
uh countermeasures and does Russia
really want that I mean does China
really want that when when that's their
economy I mean you know what's in it for
them other than poking the NATO America
UK and the eye what do you think will
happen
I think this war will just carry on and
Carry On and carry on I I I I just don't
do you think China will help Russia
um with with lethal weapons
I I don't know I just don't know I mean
I I can't I couldn't have imagined
um China doing even the idea that they
were going to do this and I I just hope
not but I I have it's impossible to say
I I one can't predict the way a dictator
is going to think
stuff thanks very much indeed for
joining us thank you